welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and we're now at the
penultimate episode of westworld season
4. this is one of the biggest head [ __ ]
i think we've had in the series so far
and it's probably got you asking a hell
of a lot of questions i even tweeted out
the other day that the episode
completely blew my mind and when
westworld replies to you you know you're
probably a host throughout this sublime
breakdown we'll be going through what
happens in it giving our theories and
also hopefully explaining some things to
stop you from losing your mind it's my
birthday weekend and i'm working on this
so the thumbs up is much appreciated and
please make sure you subscribe for the
finale next week without the way a huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into westworld
okay so we start off with bernard maeve
seemingly heading to the hoover dam that
we discovered in episode 1 was where the
sublime was at their entrance massively
juxtaposes williams who arrived in his
pilotless drone ship whilst there in
this crappy rundown jeep it shows just
how much the rebels have had to become
scavengers and it also highlights the
divide between them and the house that
we talked about last week now in the
first big
moment of the week we discovered that
this is a simulation that bernard is
running in the sublime eagle-eyed
viewers may have realized this straight
away due to the aspect ratio of the
scene with the simulation style
returning once more we also get this
line from maeve that kind of gives it
away early on
because we're in there
aren't we
now in bernard simulation we actually
also saw the tunnel that they travel
down for a split second showing how
close to the end of his arc that he's
now getting still though he allows maeve
to go first and as we learn later on
this is because he has to get to a
certain point himself in order to set
off a chain of events i'm guessing that
this will lead to william going to the
sublime to destroy it and this will be
the double extinction that bernard keeps
referring to now at this point we get to
confirm that dolores was the one who set
up the sublime back in episode 1 i
thought it could be the real charlotte
hale who had been stealing data from the
park in order to sell it as iraq however
we now know it was dolores and this
could also explain what's going on with
christina there's a very weird line at
the end of the entry when teddy tells
her the following because you're not in
this world
it's real
but you're not
now this could be very straightforward
and simply mean that she's a host it and
she don't know sit but i'm not a rapper
this would also explain why the humans
don't attack her whilst they're happy
attacking each other however he does
inform her of being a duplicate so yeah
probably not that now our editor matt
came up with a great theory and he said
that the entire thing with christina
might just be hail running a simulation
to see how to unlock the sublime similar
to what she did with caleb she could
have simply set this entire thing up to
give her a route to travel down to see
what she would do teddy may have been
introduced as a guide to make her
believe that she's free and then he
could be there to follow her every move
so that when she finally gets to the end
of this loop she hands over the
passwords and hale can finally connect
with her people i'm not going to do a
theory time because i think people are a
bit sick of it but there's also the
possibility that this itself is in the
sublime 2. that's where teddy went at
the end of season 2 and potentially a
copy of delores could exist in there as
well it would make sense that she would
set up an insurance plan after sneaking
her duplicates out and the city
destruction scene that we see playing
out also happens at night which is the
same way that it's presented in the
sublime i'll talk about one of the big
inconsistencies here later on but yeah
something to bear in mind now this idea
of copies could also come across to
maeve who we learn has been duplicated
by bernard to run this simulation of
what happens i know people will probably
be questioning what's real and what
isn't in this episode but i actually
think it's a lot more straightforward
than they initially presented as the
opening is obviously fake and i think
that the ending might be too but that's
me just theorizing about the 90-day
change that we get in the space of a
couple of seconds now bernard predicts
that mae but would abandon him to go to
the sublime to be with her daughter
instead of fighting this is why on the
second time he doesn't bring up that he
can drop her in there to be with her
daughter like he did in the simulation
instead he manipulates her he doesn't
tell her that she can be uploaded and
just promises that he'll do it when it's
all over he of course knows he's going
to die damning her to remain behind but
it's the only way that he can get her to
stay now we could have the scene from
episode 2 and we see my boya ketchita
along with the white horse white horses
have several meanings in westworld and
they can mean death like what we saw at
the end of season 2. however they can
also mean freedom and this horse is
something that a ketchiter rode out on
in the same entry now in the real world
we see how bernard plays the scenario
out learning what he did from maeve's
copy he puts something in his pants and
then he puts this behind a pipe on his
wane with maeve i'll talk about what i
think this could be at the end of the
episode as i know some of you don't like
trailer spoilers but yeah nice thing
that i think everyone needs to remember
from here we coded the title for the
video but we're gonna cut to our new
section jared's easter eggs
[Music]
now the title of this episode is
metanoial which has several different
meanings to it it can be used in several
different ways but the literal meaning
of this is change of heart now westworld
being westworld has taken this and
applied it to several different things
in this episode i'll let that chump paul
break those things down individually but
in this case it's linked to the
transcendence that hal is trying to put
the hosts through metanoia can also mean
a big change in one's life that normally
comes from a spiritual conversion
similar to what she's hoping will happen
to her you know kind uh like scientology
the word can also mean rebirth
regeneration and change which applies to
a number of characters here but i
believe that the main usage is for the
change of heart that hal is trying to
have the hosts have
[Music]
charities
that was good yet but you said hal
instead of hail so you're fired anyway i
think the person who has the biggest
change of heart is of course william he
turns against his god destroys the
kingdom and is likely going to bring
everything crashing down there are of
course lots of bible parallels here with
him being a lucifer type figure who
stands up and gets cast out of heaven
however that can also be applied to hale
2 who is locked out of paradise this
could also potentially be an adam and
eve metaphor with the pair being the
first man and woman of this new world
they were locked out of the garden of
eden after gaining knowledge similar to
how hale is locked out of the sublime
might be a reach but from here we get
the classic waking up scene that has
been a staple of the series there's been
a ton of characters this has happened
with but this is actually the first time
it struck me that it could hold a double
meaning waking up out of a dream of
course means coming to grips with
reality and the phrase to wake up can be
applied when someone sees the truth
christina is finally waking up to what's
going on and the truth of everything
only took four seasons but yeah we got
there we got that in the end what do you
mean you've known since episode one now
teddy explains her copies including
charlotte hale and he also says this
line
why are you here
i'm here to tell you the truth of what
we are
again he could be a plan put in to let
christina see the truth so that hell can
monitor her actions we of course had
that scene where the two met and hale
probed her with questions similar to how
she did to caleb when she was running
the radio test we then get a scene of
her looking in the mirror and i got lots
of allusions to the matrix here which is
a film that this season has referenced
quite a lot in that movie the famous
green code was supposed to look and fall
like raindrops and in resurrections it
appeared on morpheus mirror similar to
what happens here christina attempts to
drown herself to escape mirroring how
teddy ended his own life in season 2
because he didn't want to go any further
with dolores however christina rises up
and the journey continues which is when
we could to caleb trapped in his cell
last time there were several other
versions of him inside the other cells
but here it's just him this is because
completed the radio test and all the
other ones were simply put there to help
guide the one that would eventually make
it to the end point helen drops an
interesting line here about why she
didn't kill him your daughter and the
rebels will be here in time to join the
party
you're just here as bait
she brings up how he's purely there as
bait in order to draw his daughter in
she also mentions the cold storage that
the hosts were kept in at the park and
says that people will be placed in cold
storage after she shuts down the city
seems like her plan is to wipe humanity
out once and for all but she might be
doing what she did to william and
basically putting them in this life
support machine i think hale believes
that when the hosts no longer have the
parks to cling to that they might
finally decide to transcend turns out
that countless hosts are now offing
themselves so hail has to basically shut
this park down like it's batgirl before
it damages the ip now i can't have a
theory that caleb might also be able to
be tracked and with frankie rescuing him
he could lead hail back to the rebels
they obviously had this stuff with jay
last week but after he's taken out she
might have lost where they were we then
jump across to the group in temperance
who head out to the city lots of really
emotional moments here including maven
frankie's final exchange and also
the one the one one between the
non-stops
so it's so restrained there's very few
words spoken but man what an end to the
bromance bernard hints that stubbs
doesn't make it but i think he might be
referring to himself here as he knows
every path ends in his death he gives a
final bit of advice to stubbs which
could be brought up next week but he's
likely referring to them going left at
the gate in the subway hail announces
its doomsday but you don't exactly see
people signing up to transcend into
these cool looking bodies i love the
design of them and the pearl is
completely on display here because the
hosts believe that they're better than
the humans and that they won't harm
other hosts so there's no need to
protect their brains now william and
william is a very interesting part of
the show i love how in the end they've
both kindly gone on the same mark as
each other with them wondering about
their identities just like how william
became fixated on the maze after coming
across dolores william has become
fixated on his own identity after coming
across the outliers should probably stop
calling them both william but i love how
there's this duality in the pair human
william even thought at one point that
he could be a host so there's some
really great mirroring of these themes
carried across to his new version now
both want to just hold on to the park
more than anything with the original
constantly returning there to live out
his vices he reveals that everything
about both the humans and hosts are
broken and that we're all here to
destroy he suggests pulling the plug in
everything as the hosts are designed by
the humans and thus they will eventually
be just as bad because of how bad that
we are you can't fix a few millennia
broken dna with a [ __ ] hard drive
next we jump to times square which is
mapped out showing images of trees and
vegetation obviously civilization has
been destroyed so there's no need to
advertise anything so now the screens
just have these images on instead they
present the idea that this is a lush
green land and really times square is
it's just buildings and concrete don't
want to slag it off but that's what it
is i like this world it's all fake and
these billboards are presenting the idea
that it's something else which is a
really nice little inclusion teddy tells
christina about dolores and then she
takes him to olympiad which he destroys
after giving everyone their certain
roles we go past the worker with nareviz
written on a screen which is a word that
over time evolved into the word
narrative guessing here it's been
repurposed to show it's a visual
narrative and a nice little detail and
with it all coming down frankie and
stubbs enter the building in order to
get caleb christina and teddy pass him
too with a ladder being aware of him
which he wouldn't be without having some
knowledge of season 3. obviously how he
gained this could be hell it could be
hail and i can't wait to be proven wrong
next week so all you [ __ ] call me a
chump for once what do you mean you call
me a chump anyway now frankie and stubbs
then come across william we learn that
the circle he's in is a life support
system so there is a possibility that
this could be used to heal him probably
won't happen but it's of course meant to
resemble the circular machine that the
hosts were created in the park and this
itself was based on leonardo's vitruvian
man finally caleb and frankie are
reunited with the former initially
believing that it's one of hale's tricks
however it's real even if caleb isn't he
calls himself real but potentially we
could see the death of his body with it
shutting down due to how weak that this
copy is caleb is of course already dead
so i kind of think that they might have
his final farewell next week with his
host body perishing maeve and bernard
then arrive at the tower and we see the
right drones that are based on edtr09
from the movie robocop they're about as
useful as that was too with bernard
running through millions and millions of
simulations to decipher their encryption
now at this point bernard walks through
the compound and in the back we can
catch someone who has transcending show
that they still seem to remain on earth
they just leave their human body and now
they can't participate in the sex and
murder that the hosts did in the park at
this point bernard tells me the truth
about how they can't really win and all
that bernard is actually trying to do is
save a tiny part of everything i think
the people he's referring to saving are
the rebels and with them no longer being
hunted they'll actually be able to live
have kids and restart civilization
rehobem always predicted a complete
population collapse that was impossible
to get beyond and this very much lines
up with what bernard is saying and that
there's not really any escaping this
hail goes to take the plunge herself as
i think she's genuinely fed up of the
[ __ ] that comes from all the games
nice detail how the new host bodies
don't have any arms and she of course
spent season three and four clawing away
at his if you don't have arms you can't
self arm and this will
and this will stop the hosts going wild
and just ripping their pearls out
because they're sick of hail's control
we then get a pun so bad it could be
something in one of these videos i heard
you were losing your mind
i just didn't think they meant literally
now both hail and maeve are of course
hosts and the pair juxtapose each other
in several ways hail is of course a copy
of dolores so her time in the park was
spent under the control of the humans
much like how maeves was too however
whereas maeve got to see the good in
humanity through those that had freed
her hail was taken from a version that
hadn't yet met caleb so she'd seen only
the bad if you think about it when hale
was swapped over dolores was very much
coming off the back of the season 2
massacre so she very much carries this
mind state still though she sees herself
as a higher life form she doesn't
actually have the experience that maeve
does nor the humanity to truly
understand why the hosts are offing
themselves upon coming face to face with
the outliers now made for dolores in the
penultimate episode of season 3 so this
is a nice mirroring of that with her
fighting her other copy here too hale
touches upon how transcending is just
one part of her plan so there's likely
something else beyond this hale believes
that the sublime will see their new
world and join them and they will of
course be aware of everything due to
their ability to run simulations and
monitor the world whilst taylor may
fight it out bernard enters the command
level of the tower and william also
shows up as a bit of a wild card he
firstly shoots maeve and then hail
before going to bernard and killing him
too before this though we catch bernard
leaving a little message
if you choose to give her that choice
you can't miss
reach with your left hand
this likely ties in with the little
things that we saw him set up but it's
cut short by william's arrival again
there's this weird transition from day
to night in this scene which mirrors how
the end is depicted in the sublime
whether this is the end of bernard
remains to be seen but it does come
across that way with him revealing how
he dies in every single scenario the
tower is of course destroyed which is
likely the part that he's in and he may
be completely unsalvageable though there
is the possibility of return which we'll
get into in just a bit now he has a
poetic send-off with us seeing his
entrance into the sublime from earlier
in the season in which he chased after
his son it's also important to bear in
mind that the entire time that bernard
was running the simulation he was in
this exact spot where he'd end up dying
looking back there's a lot of
foreshadowing and i love how the place
that he played it all out in the sublime
is also the same place that he
eventually dies at in the real world so
yes i do think he's probably gone and in
his vision that we saw back in episode 3
he didn't go past this point william
sets everyone up to basically go on
rampage mode in gta and we watch as they
all fight to the death frankie is shot
during this and though they make it out
the city descends into chaos we then
curtail the man in black leaving to the
sound of david bowie's man who sold the
world now this song has had many
interpretations with even bowie not out
and out saying what it's actually about
there are theories that the songs
narrator encounters a kind of
doppelganger which is suggested in the
lyrics who knows not me we never lost
control this could be reflected in
william who of course came face to face
with himself before bringing it all down
taking at face value though the piece is
about the man who sold the world
reflecting how william basically
commodified humanity and this led to its
downfall now for the next part of the
video i want to talk about the main
trailer that was shown and how part of
that which we haven't seen yet will play
into the finale next week there's only
really about two shots but they are
important however if you don't want to
know that then i suggest that you check
out now i'll see you next week and i
hope you have a good one anyway we have
a shot of william riding towards the
sublime on horseback ushering in images
of death he's clearly there to destroy
it and i'm guessing that bernard left it
open because he wanted herald in the
extinction for the host that he was too
talking about due to time and the
sublime they've been alive for millennia
as well and maybe they're just sick of
it as they can't really self-terminate i
don't think they can maybe not but we
also have hail appearing at the dam as
well although he said bernard is
unsalvageable she could have taken his
head as it contains the key to open it
however it might already be open because
yeah bernard did leave it open so it all
just seems like it could be part of his
plan now this looks like a big action
scene which is likely why he left the
item behind so that they'd have reserves
this could be a gun or something else
that helps a person to defeat hell
anyway that's the main things i think
could happen i know they always drop a
promo for the next episode after one
releases but when reviewers get these
early that isn't attached to it so i've
got no idea what's going on now i
thought we'd talk about the season so
far before we head into the finale next
week i think this is up there as being
probably the second best season at this
point season one was of course the gold
standard and i felt that season two
dipped a bit with us getting a bit more
of a dip with season three i did go back
and rewatch all them before season four
started and three has grown on me a lot
i think this season really recaptures
why a lot of us fell in love with the
show in the very first place it's full
of big reveals nice comments on the
human condition and a narrative that
keeps you coming back week to week we're
also at a point now where i feel like
every character's journey is really
exciting to follow whether it's
christina slowly scratching away at that
itch to learn the truth hale's starting
to see her empire slip away or just the
father and daughter relationship with
caleb and frankie it all really works
for me this was another really solid
episode setting up what's probably gonna
be a great finale and i will of course
be back next week to break it all down
in the meantime i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so if that's you
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want some emails to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
sandman which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over the full
netflix season explained how it ties in
with the comics and what could be coming
so if you've got questions that's the
video to go to right now get get over
there well that i know if you don't go i
won't be mad i'll just be disappointed
but uh thanks for sticking through this
video i appreciate it take care yourself
peace